nicolas vidal bonjour très heureux d'y
retrouver ce matin sur ft france alors
le pas sanitaire pourrait être prolongée
ce mois-ci jusqu'à l'été 2022 ou le
disait et ce à quoi doit-on s'attendre
quoi et bien bon jour il va falloir
attendre le 19 octobre prochain pour que
l'assemblée nationale se penche sur la
question de la prolongation du passé ni
terre notre boussole notre gps social à
tous et comme j'aime bien les adages je
me souviens de mon professeur d'histoire
qui nous disait au collège à la ceinture
est un contrôle vous guette eh bien le
19 octobre ce sera à la salle rené c'est
pas demain que vous retrouver la liberté
et se passe à terre c'est un peu comme
les masques en mars 2020 qui ne servait
à rien et à l'époque de toute façon nous
les français nous étions bien trop
stupides pour les mettre correctement et
pour saisir toute la subtilité de
l'élastique
plus fort encore début 2021 le passé
iter c'était un tube de complotiste et
de conspirationnistes qui zonaient dans
les bas-fonds de la république en
postant des photos de gens qui faisait
des triangles avec leurs mains mais pour
gouvernement s'était juré craché il
était hors de question donc travées la
victime des français avec machin pareil
vous n'y pensez pas aujourd'hui un peu
plus pourtant olivier ferrand l'a répété
sur tous les tons ainsi que plusieurs
membres grandement désigne la majorité
présidentielle et bien aujourd'hui mes
chers amis de la camisole sanitaire ça
risque d'être double voire triple ration
pour tout le monde alors ne boudez pas
votre plaisir vous allez vous régaler le
gouvernement veut par tous les moyens en
remettre une grosse louche jusqu'à l'été
2022 et ce matin ce matin je lance un
appel à nos chers députés programmée dès
maintenant vos réveils et soyez présents
dans l'hémicycle dès le 19 octobre à
loeb pour participer au débat avec votre
passé iter ne l'oublié pas parce que ce
serait ballot de se faire refouler il
s'agirait pas d'avoir piscine pédalo
gymnastique suédoise ou un cours en
retard de langue de bois en plus voter
c'est plus simple que m masque il faut
juste au pied sur un bouton il n'ya pas
d'élastiques à la rigueur une led se
suffit alors est ce qu'on peut reprocher
au gouvernement nicolas de vouloir
réagir si le virus venait à resurgir
brusquement avant l'élection
présidentielle ben en fait magali c'est
un peu ce qui fait peur au gouvernement
c'est que la démocratie repartent
brusquement
seul coup sans crier gare alors oui il
faut que je m'explique car je viens
employer un terme très anciens qui nous
vient tout droit du 5e siècle avant
jésus-christ exhumés non pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout je repars ce les
bases de l'histoire ce terme exhumé de
la grèce antique communément appelée par
nos anciens comme la galerie la
démocratie alors là oui alors ça paraît
un peu ésotérique comme ça mais la
démocratie s'appuie sur une définition
exacte je cite c'est une forme de
gouvernement dans laquelle la
souveraineté appartient au peuple et à
ainsi gouverner fin de citation alors
oui je sais c'est moins glamour moins
innovants - french tech que la star
thème des chaînes emmanuel macron c'est
moins nanotechnologique et sas pilote
pas comme un droit mais ce truc a fait
ses preuves mais il ya un problème de
taille car le retour brutal à la
démocratie pourrait déclencher un choc
anaphylactique dangereux pour
gouvernement c'est pour ça que la
posologie la plus efficace c'est de
prolonger l'état d'urgence jusqu'en
juillet 2022 pour s'habituer petit à
petit mais il faut prendre en compte une
contre-indication dans lordonnance bien
ces trois fois rien je vous rassure mais
ça s'appelle la présidentielle en abyme
prochain et là ça se complique comment
faire le gouvernement va-t-il et
inventer les isoloirs qr code ou va-t-il
proposer un quiz par internet pour voter
pour son candidat entre deux poses sur
facebook et hino story est à g et bien
on n'en sait rien mais gérald darmanin
le shérif entier hackers qui dégaine
plus vite son ministère a lâché c'est
jean jacques bourdin co gouvernement de
travailler au vote à distance alors non
c'est pas par correspondance assez à
distance comme il est prévoyant notre
pétillante l'intérieur il y a déjà
réfléchi à tout réforme
constitutionnelle est identique une
identité numérique et tout le toutim
néanmoins il faudra quand même éviter
d'utiliser whatsapp facebook ou
messenger parce que si ça bug le jour j
ça sera une présidentielle version
erreur 404 mais pourtant un nicolas le
gouvernement ne s'est pas prononcé sur
le pass sanitaires pour la
présidentielle à ce jour et oui mais
c'est bien le problème ce gouvernement
qui nous a tout dit et son contraire
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
méridienne résiste et surtout pas la
cohérence rappelez-vous les masques
rappelez vous le passez anitea on nous
disait jamais idem pour la vaccination
obligatoire jamais jamais jamais selon
le virologue emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
les sagnes en soignante dû tomber la
blouse pour la piquouse sinon c'est pas
de bras direction pôle emploi et voilà
qu'un amendement présenté par le
sénateur jonnier était dans les tuyaux
bouchée du sénat pour imposer la
vaccination obligatoire à tout le monde
dès janvier 2022 hier il a été rejeté en
commission ouf mais aujourd'hui amis de
la démocratie neurasthénique nous sommes
entrés dans une ère où notre liberté
gribouillée dans une cuillère code et de
mails pour être enfermés dans le piston
d'une seringue la réalité c'est que ce
pas sanitaire n'a rien de sanitaires et
qu'il est profondément politique et que
le gouvernement va tenter par tous les
moyens de le faire traîner jusqu'en
avril 2022 car dans la macro ni et je
termine par là tout ce qui n'est pas
interdit est obligatoire merci beaucoup
nicolas c'est con à sainte juliette au
jeu c'est plus du tout mais je sais
qu'ils avaient toujours le contrôle
d'une gaieté en tout cas voilà c'est
attrayant mais sur get merci beaucoup
nicolas pour elle cet édito